i it's just not in like it wouldn't be
wait face lap or booty
space sliding that's like kind of
standard practice standard
you ever slap a titty though no no
not not in like a in a funny way i have
yeah what is that thing called when you
run up to somebody and do that
i don't know but yeah just you do that
to a fat person yeah they just happened
to meet you all the time you know what
i'm saying
but
oh my man over here speaking spanish now
huh um
oh what'd you say i really like this
kind bar
nailed it you nailed it bro like a
breath of fresh air i got a breath of
fresh air
like a deep breath bro i know i know
like
the dogs costa baby but i know like
six like maybe seven things probably no
more but i know like
pinchy right there you go pluto
there you go the way you say things is
so fast
tortuga turtle turtle papas
french fries or potatoes or a father
pepinos
uh pickles cucumber
lachugh lettuce you can tell that i
worked at burger king right with a bunch
of his many people
sesame seed bun and turtle for some
reason i don't throw it in the middle
because the the bread looks like a
turtle
um yeah dude i don't know i'm
whitewashed as [ __ ] bro
i wish i think i might have told you
yeah my dad's from el salvador
and he speaks fluent spanish um it's
different though than from like mexico
spanish yeah
there's slightly different things i
think yeah different slang
yeah different basically the same like
we could we could communicate yeah
they yeah that's what my dad always told
me it's like just maybe here and there's
some little things that might be
different but it's
spanish yeah and the spanish in spain is
hella different though kind of
i mean they all have the lisp for some
reason like yeah there was like a king
that had a lisp and he was like hey
we're all talking like this and they
were like all right
for some reason so they have that and
they have like uh vosotros they say
like a voice and vosotros and they have
different slang too
but you i can you can communicate but
you can get by oh yeah yeah
more than get by you can communicate
okay there's certain things we're gonna
have to be like wait what and then
they'll be like oh this is what we say
for this and you'll be like okay fine
like i'm good yeah like the story that i
heard
uh was that my dad was talking to me in
spanish when i was a kid
and i was starting to speak it but when
i started school
i was having a hard time speaking
english in school
so then he just stopped speaking to me
in spanish which
i could understand him being an
immigrant right he's probably like
others doesn't want to get bullied and
[ __ ] yeah just just do english just
english but
i really wish that they talked to me in
spanish so i wish i knew [ __ ] spanish
but
it's funny like they speak fluent my
dad's more of like that
calm speaker where like he kind of like
spanish you know i'm saying
but then i have an aunt but bruh she she
speaks the whole [ __ ] scripture
in like three seconds
i'm like are you gonna breathe at all
like shoulders you know when i first
went to a catholic church i was shocked
that the uh
priest isn't reading off a bible the
fool's like reading the scripture off
the top of his head
do you notice that [ __ ] i know because i
know they always thought they had the
book right there like i assume they were
reading
maybe i just went to a really dope ass
dude this [ __ ] was david wasn't
at a church bro
just like god has told me that i
[Music]
because uh i did this girl that was uh
like vietnamese catholic
uh i went to first of all the whole
catholicism kind of tripped me out a bit
because i went to a christian church
right
christian church we have like drums and
[ __ ] yeah that turned up
yeah so it's different right but this
one you know
they're doing the prayers the kneeling
thing yeah watching this [ __ ] smoke
that comes out with his belt yeah
i'm like yo what [ __ ] is this game of
thrones weapon and [ __ ]
yeah they start [ __ ] cutting people's
heads
but the dude homie up there was just
like reading scripture off of
just the top of his head and then we're
reading along the the bo i'm like yo
this will memorize this [ __ ] like
what is going on what page is this on
this i always thought they had the
because they had the book i thought
because like they would tell stories in
between uh but i assumed like that the
[ __ ] was right there going on
i believe it because i can't like you
know i've met
super religious people and stuff and
they'll say something and there's always
like
just like bible verse john three men and
they start i'm like okay how do you
remember this [ __ ] bro that's terrible
so i
not even like i wouldn't second guess it
like a priest probably knows that [ __ ]
like the back of his hand and [ __ ]
but like what you said about christian
church right so i grew up catholic
uh i hated going to church because it
was
so boring the word catholic church the
worst i'm sorry i don't know if this
will fan somebody but no it's
like church is the most boring [ __ ]
because it's uh
what's the word a ritualistic so there's
a lot of rituals that you have to do
and so it's super rigid you know it's
the same as it was back in the day stand
up
put the little [ __ ] [ __ ] down you
knee down stand up knee
hold happy with you yeah also with you
big facts right now any of my friends
who are catholic when they invite me to
the wedding i say no
because it's [ __ ] two hours yeah two
three hours let me just cover that after
the reception
yeah the reception but then i want to
shout out to my uh buddy reggie you know
i like shout out to everybody
reggie congratulations i love you
congrats on that marriage
catholic baby you for inviting me to
your [ __ ] wedding that [ __ ] was three
hours [ __ ] long
terrible so i got prepped after that my
other my other buddy uh
quaint he got married again this was
[ __ ] hilarious so his
he's now catholic because his wife is
catholic and they can only get married
if he converts
right so he's like okay is that a
catholic thing well his family wants
her family yeah okay so this new this
[ __ ] got a catholic name his
name is antoine
[Applause]
vietnamese name and now his name is now
he's antoine the only person i know what
antoine is from deuce bigelow male jig
yeah so when he invited me to his wife i
was [ __ ] catholic i knew i know it's
going to happen so
what i did i got smashed before i went
to the world yeah
and then me and my buddy gobble were
just drinking i was like i might be
going hell but your boy christian so we
have to figure this out real quick
but no speaking of that because i
remember we hated going to church like
we despise it as kids but just imagine
like everybody knows catholic church a
little ass kid right
when we you know we have i have two
older brothers we just want to play and
[ __ ] bro and like
church is like over an hour sometimes
but one time my mom's friend ann
invited us to her church which was a
christian church
right and you're like this [ __ ] pop bro
we were like [ __ ] we don't want to
[ __ ] go momma's like let's just go
you know we're going to hang out with
her afterwards so let's just go to this
anyway so we go
live band people up dancing and [ __ ] i'm
like
what the [ __ ] is this okay i'm like hey
god what's pi
like i was like if this was what church
was like maybe we would enjoy going
so like i mean but dude catholic church
you're catholic yeah yeah dude easter
easter
on on church i don't know why because i
hated it so much that's why i couldn't
speak it right now
dude going to church on easter that's
like a four-hour
[ __ ] day bro yeah and then ash
wednesday you gotta go oh my gosh
wednesday put that [ __ ] on my head
never finished ash wednesday oh terrible
we were last like a week
it was just trash
because my dad didn't follow it right so
my parents were divorced
every friday we would switch houses so
like if it was during that time and we
went to my mom's like we're waiting for
dinner
she's like we're gonna have fish it's
i'm like [ __ ]
like fish i'm just like god damn it yeah
it was weird because like when going to
the whole catholic thing i was like
i wanna know i now understand why all my
catholic homies are pieces of [ __ ]
yeah it's so boring they hate the
religion dude it's so boring
like for a young person did you do
confirmation and communion and all that
dude i did that
when i was like 13 two yeah i was like
14. yeah bro my mom's like we want you
guys to get baptized
so they sent us to a [ __ ] church oh
you got baptized at
13 yeah so you were like it was like
baby baby baby and then
you know so it was like oh my god bro it
was a whole that's hilarious
alex goes to do you want to talk i just
grab the water myself throw it on my
head like
peace with god also with you uh no
[ __ ] the [ __ ] no it was all over with
you it was a class
so but it was a lot of older kids right
yeah
me and my brother bro it was pointless
because i could
this is how much percent we focused in
that class i
could not tell you one thing that we
went over in that class
but we had to do it every sunday until
it was like a [ __ ] two months or
three months thing
then we got everything at once but it
was like when we were 14. yeah
same i had to go on a retreat with a
bunch of weirdos
like i don't even know it was some
mountain [ __ ] place oh what are
catholic retreats like
weird as [ __ ] weird so it was so weak
okay so we get there
first of all all the other kids were
private school kids and they all knew
everything about the bible i didn't know
[ __ ] about the bible so they were like
the
like raising their hand for everything i
didn't know anything and like but when i
would see them interact they were like
just [ __ ] bag people so i was like [ __ ]
these i didn't like anybody there
[ __ ] all these snotty weirdo kids i
don't like anybody uh so i just
i just stayed to myself but i remember
some lady washed my feet at some point
and like like
it's like the symbol okay there was
candle lights there like i went into a
room and like there was like candles and
she's watching your sister watching
the jesus christ thing yeah that jesus
but it was like who's i was like are we
gonna [ __ ] right now
it's kind of like whoa i'm getting some
sex vibes in here
the power of christ compels you but it
was and peace be with you
it was dude we watched the walk to
remember for some reason what the have
you ever seen that movie is something
yeah
yeah i don't know why they showed us
that uh but we did that
we did another thing where like it was
like activity time and we all shook
hands like shake my hands
and if you felt like this little like
scratch on the inside of your palm you
were blind like you
you were just told to just do that like
so say you you started shaking hands
they told like three people in the crowd
like do this
right and by the end of it everyone's
[ __ ] doing this because but you touch
everybody
and at the end of it they were like oh
yeah by the way that's how aids spreads
and then it was like wait what [ __ ] i
swear to god
that's how quickly aids could spread
abstain from sex and i was like
huh like why did you just say that yeah
why don't you just say that also what
yeah but you didn't tell us to put a
condom on our finger we could have like
yeah they were like also god loves you
go to bed
and i was like what in the [ __ ] is that
i left that
after i did my communion i was like i'll
never come back to church again after
that experience i was like i'm done my
dad forced me to do it i was like i told
my dad after i was like this is the
worst mistake you made i'll literally
never weird because
the way people in introduce people to
religion is so odd sometimes right
like i've i've told the story before
about this one dude who just literally
grabbed me by my shoulders
and it was this thing called gethsemane
and gibson is some it's like a like a
place of worship in the bible right
mm-hmm
like holy holy ground or something i
might be [ __ ] i used to be a pastor
but i did a lot of drinking yeah because
you married uh bart and geo right yeah i
used to be a pastor and everything but i
don't remember [ __ ] anymore because you
know your boy living in
sin but um
yeah so there we used this thing called
gethsemane on riverside and there was
uh this group called kccc korean
korean christian crusaders for christ
okay all right a lot of seas too many
seasons
you know this organization might be very
different from college to college to
college or campus or whatever right
the one that i went to in uc riverside
was a [ __ ] cult right
and i went there for like a day and i'm
like [ __ ] you freaks i'm like doing this
[ __ ] you know a bunch of
[ __ ] they would try to control small
aspects of your life like they said that
oh if you join kccc
you cannot uh date anybody until your
third year in college and i'm like
why and i remember when they told me
that what i said was this i was like
where does it say that in the bible
i know right dead silent yeah they
couldn't say anything
because it doesn't say that in the bible
you just made up your rules there was no
college and bible i know
i know jesus over here like well not
until you're a [ __ ]
junior in college in university
i don't understand the the logic behind
it right right
and so you know we had this so i
remember we were sitting down and there
was this girl named
anne marie she sat down a little
filipino girl little sweet girl
and she was sleepy and then she kind of
leaned her head on my shoulder and she
he goes one of the the leaders of the
group comes and goes hey we don't do
that here yeah i said we don't do what
i'm already pissed right he goes you
guys can't do that i can see david's in
the corner like
the whole time just like just because
i've already heard the whole dating
spirit so i'm already irritated right
because now they're just using
the religion at however the [ __ ] they
want yeah right like a bunch of trash
bags
and he goes we don't do that here and
i'm like do what like you guys can't do
that
i'm like no
you can't sleep
what the [ __ ] are you saying you know
get on my shoulder and we're gonna [ __ ]
after this yeah and then i'm gonna make
her deep throat my dick
that's where the double double guac walk
came
the [ __ ] is wrong with you but like that
type of behavior pushes people away from
religion of course
yeah like could you imagine just you
going to that [ __ ] they're just like
scratch my scratch you have aids now
children i remember even being young and
being like
like it just came out of nowhere like it
was like i don't know like wow
go to sleep we'll talk tomorrow like
what the [ __ ] is that and then we made
gingerbread houses the next one
i remember we had one babysitter that
was super religious
that was the first time ever like
everything
everything there was always an extreme
with them right so i remember
they we knew that they were really
religious when we started getting
babysit by them because even when we
were going to eat a snack
they forced us to sit at the table and
pray and we didn't pray at my house
right so
like we couldn't just eat we had a god
is great god is good thank you for our
food amen before
anything um but we kind of knew that and
my older brother
was just like messing around one day and
they were saying something and my older
brother's like ah
that's not even true though because we
just evolved from monkeys
right wow and bruh we they forced us to
sit on a couch and watch
three hours of jesus christ movies and
educate us on jesus christ
bro and there was one time i got sent to
a corner
because it said i said god oh you use
god's name in vain you're in trouble so
like i had to go wow
but these people were so like extreme
like i remember we were telling our mom
these stories and she didn't believe her
but the last one she did so like the
first one
was st patrick's day right and we were
just like oh it's st
patrick's day they're like oh you
shouldn't celebrate st patrick's day and
we're like why
i was maybe in first grade or something
like that they're like uh
leprechauns are real and they actually
kill people
so when you when you celebrate you go to
a church are you sure no that's not like
a church
no no this isn't a church i'm just a
babysitter that was super religious
super religious right and she's like
yeah they're coming for your partner
yeah they're talking about how they'll
kill us and stuff so we shouldn't
celebrate
we're like all right so we just like all
right we told our mom she's like uh
whatever
but the one that was like the big one
was halloween was coming up
and so we were like me and my brother's
talking about like what costumes we want
to get or some [ __ ] like that
and they tell us like you guys better
not go out trick-or-treating on
halloween
we're like why they're like witches are
real which is come and they prey on kids
and they kidnap kids
so they're like when you when you step
away from your parents you could get
kidnapped
from a witch and they'll kill you and
we're just like
okay but they're like dead serious
telling us that right it sounds like a
joke but it's like dead serious yeah
so we're just like what the [ __ ] and
like at the end of the day right the
same lady is getting dressed up to go to
a halloween party
right yeah and my brother michael still
talk about this because like she's
dressing up
right after they told us not to
celebrate hollywood that's what she
dressed up as
some sort of princess or some [ __ ] like
i forget which one
and she was like wait what she say and
we told her like she said like she told
us not
that we shouldn't be going
trick-or-treating this year because uh
there's witches coming out this year
and they're gonna kidnap kids and kill
them like what the [ __ ]
so then my mom finally went and talked
to them and then she just took us out of
that [ __ ]
yeah but it's like they were so like
that wasn't really like a religious
thing but they were so religious
to where i can't tell you how many times
we got sent to a corner because we said
god
on accident like oh my god or something
like that they would send us to a corner
oh you used god's name in vain
it's crazy how people can take anything
i mean religion is the main has been the
main one for a long time
to like make people go [ __ ] like
people that are nuts attached to it and
do weird-ass [ __ ] like that but people
can literally take
anything and run with it and become just
if you're a [ __ ] weirdo you're gonna
be a [ __ ] weirdo with no matter what
it is but
like religion is like such a has been
the main thing for that like the main
vehicle for that the whole time
i don't know if what i just said made
any sense no i don't know about it but
yeah that's well because like religion
is highly based on faith right
and like i feel like because religion
finds people who are kind of
you know they need a lot of help yeah so
when they see that can be a source of
them gaining their sanity back
it becomes their whole identity to the
point where they kind of like ostracize
the people that have been around them
their whole lives yeah
because it sounds like if you don't [ __ ]
with this you're you're a sinner you're
going to go to hell
i need to change your life if you're not
with me you're against me yeah which is
like the worst way to [ __ ] go about
it
right but for some people it can
actually do great oh yeah actually it
makes their life great and
i haven't killed anybody yet dude i got
my back bro
i think it's i think religion is cool in
that sense but i just i would
when i don't like it is when you have
people like that right oh yeah that are
so hardcore you're wrong for this
because this is this like
i think it's cool like if if having
religion and thinking like there's
someone out there protecting you right
and you know you just keep it to
yourself so it helps you live
like a good life and that type of [ __ ]
it's cool but just i can't stand what
people were trying to like
force that [ __ ] down your throat some of
the girls in the church were so [ __ ]
funny because
you know they were horny as [ __ ] they
wanted they wanted that d
you know anybody they would try to find
these random loopholes to keep their
virginity which was like
you're basically [ __ ] getting ass
[ __ ] or something legit so there was a
girl that i knew at
church like she i remember she was
talking about how keeping your virginity
is so important right and somebody else
at the church was like
we [ __ ] yesterday she goes no we had
he said you had we had anal sex i'm
still a virgin
wow and i was just shocked i'm like
what what the [ __ ] are you talk you're
[ __ ] she's like sucking dick
you know she's getting eaten out she's
getting [ __ ] in the ass but as long as
you go in the [ __ ]
she's still a virgin very good
come on the face facial non the [ __ ]
all right
i told this story too there was another
girl at the church
where she was so adamant arguing with
people that she was still a virgin
because she had sex but nobody came
inside her so she's still a virgin
i support her
you're [ __ ] now like you've had 12
dicks in your mouth
in the ass like that's like next level
[ __ ] right there
you need lube you need like all kinds of
[ __ ] like you don't get a lot of
preparation first you go in the [ __ ]
face
yeah you're doing backwards you're
actually far beyond a virgin dude yeah
right ass takes time like
possibly an enema if you're trying to
really go about it like a professional
i mean a thumb at least thumb circles
maybe some toys
like you need to go to the store my man
is a professional
yeah i mean there's steps involved right
the toys
he's like this jacket i'm gonna give her
my amazon wishlist real quick it's like
you gotta make sure you use this jelly
though because this one
i'm just saying unless you're just going
in there raw and then i mean that's a
messy
we already heard that story yeah people
got on his ass
how dare you you asked him to [ __ ] her
the answer you got mad cause she [ __ ] oh
yeah
they were so upset they were mad but
whatever man i didn't expect it
sorry she [ __ ] on me
like hey if you guys [ __ ] on you
might be a little happier
it was kind of funny now in retrospect
i've only tried still a good place you
know once in my life
against my will and i did not want to do
that
i just don't i've never liked the idea
of anal sex
so i don't i don't mind if like she
wants me to like i don't know like
lightly fingered or put my finger around
the area that's tight like i think
that's funny
hey that's tight both ways
it's like when you when you wanted like
what's called ding dong ditch so you
just kind of like circle around
the doorbell a little bit he's like this
dude is pinky like this tickling
butthole perimeters you're just taking
them
like if a girl's like hey i want you to
like finger my ass i'll be okay that's
fine right yeah yeah
but sticking my comment into the ass
is something i never wanted to do
because poopy comes out here yeah
i mean it's true yeah i've done it i've
done it
like two three times one time is enough
for me man like i just i remember what i
did
here's the disappointing part it didn't
feel that good
yeah it doesn't it's like it's like in
the beginning and then the rest is
cavernous and i'm like this doesn't feel
right right
right i think it's just like the kinky
aspect of it i think
it's like we're being dirty right now i
think that's what it is but for me it's
like
i'm saying this after that experience
i've tried it a couple times
the same thing i was like this is just
kind of cool after the first time i was
kind of
like uh i'm not sure like i prefer the
other necessary when i was
when i was uh what's the word what's the
kind word when i was
tapping that ass you know from the back
i didn't want to do it so much my dick
started getting soft as i was pumping
oh yeah i just didn't want to do it
but she liked anal sex she liked it she
liked that she wanted it that's like her
go-to [ __ ]
like warms her up so i don't know what
catholic is with her
i'm like what religion are you i'm
catholic so technically
i'm still a virgin yeah so like i
remember when i went in i was like
it's not that tight it doesn't feel good
yeah what's the point of this yeah i
think after the last time
when i was doing it i was kind of just
like yeah this ain't for me yeah
i don't know yeah yeah but i mean if it
makes the girl happy i'm like
that's because it came out as a snicker
bar
that wasn't the last time
[Laughter]
he goes i'm gonna try this again maybe
this time would be a little different
nice the same i prefer i prefer the
other
yeah yeah for the other hole
for the other hole you know
i prefer the other i just try to be uh
nice
but i just prefer the other hole oh yeah
then the other hole
then the other the other the other the
other holes are nice vaginas are way
better yes
and they're built for this reason and
they work there's a lot of things that
you learn
like would you just start having sex
with more than one partner i think what
i learned early on was that
finding finding somebody a girl that
could do a hand job really well is not
easy at all because it's like you know
what you're here
i mean like i can [ __ ] my [ __ ] up you
know what i'm saying
so like my [ __ ] [ __ ] my [ __ ] taught a1
yeah my hand game a1 you know what i'm
saying so obviously you just had a
couple ones
but uh you do the twisty no not really
you need to twist it
i don't use lotion i don't do any of
that [ __ ] you're just a bear just bare
bro
wow she's got something on my hands and
that's not from that's not from lifting
weights right there
that's rugged dude that's from the dick
there's an outback
yeah that that's a hard one some even
sometimes like [ __ ]
have been there it was a girl that i
knew not new yeah we were dating for a
bit but she was so
adamant that her [ __ ] head game was
good
her hand jobs were the best terrible
trash both yeah but i think it's because
whoever she was having sex with before
he liked rough [ __ ] i think she kind of
assumed that she was with that
everybody for three years yeah so her
the way she would give hand jobs and
blow jobs
was like she would like i had a million
dollars at the base of my dick and she
was trying to squeeze it out
and i remember she was like you ready
for this like she was like
worse like don't like don't hype
yourself up
a big [ __ ] game and i remember
that hand job was the most painful hand
job i've ever had in my life
like it was like she was interrogating
my dick like where is it
yeah and i just remember it being the
[ __ ] worst and it hurts so bad but i
didn't want to hurt her feelings right
because like she
is getting turned on by the fact that
she believes that this is her skill like
this is what's going to get guys off
but i'm pretty sure the guy that she had
was before he likes pain and like
that that choking whipping [ __ ] yeah
weird weird but she i just
ah i i if i think about it now i can
remember how
painful it was especially because after
she did that
she went to the blow job right and for
her she's like my shit's
oh my god and she's like over here like
i'm deep throat queen
right oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah he's like
went straight to the base super fast
like didn't pull back
so definitely the way she was doing was
geared towards her
long-term relationship he liked painful
[ __ ]
and i just remembered after that like
hand jobs i got
kind of scared of them i'm like i don't
want to test this anymore
yeah let me do it you know i mean yeah
absolutely yeah when you get a bad one
too like i remember
like i had one girlfriend and it was
like when i first lost my virginity
right so you're doing it and stuff and
then she was giving me blow jobs and i'm
just like i think
i thought i thought this was gonna be so
much better so like i kind of wasn't
even a fan of
[ __ ] but then the next girl that i
had was
that one
you know it's it's cool though you know
i don't really know
because i don't know
hey if you good at it i appreciate you
that's all i want to say
i've been in that situation with the
hard and like i was trying to like
because you're right you don't want to
hurt their feelings
but i was just kind of like i was like
listen listen up of course
straight
i'm not circumcised so like when you
have a rough one
and you're not circumcised way more
sensitive it's sensitive i've had that a
couple times too where
so i know what you're talking about when
it's like rough because i've had to go
like oh you
chill for a chill baby like just let go
a little bit the teeth
like your teeth aren't that sharp but
for some reason on like it
on your dick it feels like a race but if
they know how to use it just like
lightly that's not
oh
no but now i'm not saying like [ __ ]
biting like you're trying to like
like clean off yourself
like a very soft gray really it doesn't
hurt it hurts
i got gorilla scan bro damn man
i got all my skin so like my [ __ ] dick
you saw that that [ __ ] like
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] ready for war you
watch have you seen
it before it yeah the clown when he's
clapping you've come out you're like
i'm gonna talk about that [ __ ] oh my
gosh
versus predator he's like oh [ __ ] i'm
like oh [ __ ]
why am i feeling like this right now
people gonna cross his legs
if they do it like here and there and
they're not like biting on you it's like
i don't mind it
but i'm not saying like i want you to
literally peel off my [ __ ] skin
yeah you know what i'm saying wow i told
this story back like when i remember the
first time
did a whole video about this and i
remember when i was writing this writing
the the vlog that i was doing
i started [ __ ] laughing about how
embarrassing this is because
my this is my first girlfriend this was
the
second girlfriend that i had so but she
was the third person i've ever had sex
with right
but i've never been with somebody who
was experienced
as this girl was her [ __ ] game was
trash too
but she loved dirty talking right i've
never done that before
the first two girls that i ever had sex
with never did this [ __ ] right and she
didn't warm me up to this
and she should know like i'm new at this
like you're my literally you know
you're my third girl
but she was an older girl so she was way
more experienced and i was actually the
first asian guy that she's been with
he was a filipino girl everybody else
before that was black it's a lot of
pressure
yeah yeah yeah yeah a lot of pressure
yeah i mean a lot of pressure
before anyone starts yeah i was like let
me see your phone let me see what these
guys look like
some dick pics yeah you know but show me
some armpits
she basically didn't warm me up telling
me that she likes the dirty talk but she
was like right off the jump with it
right getting crazy
like saying crazy and she just said one
thing and this is like one of the most
mortifying things that ever happened to
me she goes
she goes whose [ __ ] is this i was like
yours
question mark when i write what i said i
was like
idiot yours
i was like she was like say that she's
like chastising me and she's [ __ ]
writing me like the [ __ ]
say it's your puzzle you're having a
whole lesson she's like so basically
as i'm writing you gotta say she was
kind of dope in the sense that she was
the first person that kind of
vocalized what she liked and disliked in
bed
that's dope yeah i like that she was the
life lesson for me where after that now
i communicated not obviously not as
forward as she was
but now it's like oh you got to let me
know what you like because yeah you know
not everybody's the same
but i remember after we were hooking up
a couple of times but one day one time i
just thought i gave her like great dick
boy right here
no but this will do remember after we
[ __ ] i don't know why i had this like
abundance amount of confidence i looked
dead into this woman so i said
how'd you like that
all right tell me why she looked at me
she goes all right ashley's reading a
book
it's okay she goes she goes okay all
right
oh yeah my [ __ ] heart shattered to
him i was like what you mean
and you got hot right your skin turned
hot
i was like would you be she was like
well you know there's like certain
things you did and i was like
hold on let me get my notepad like
writing [ __ ] she goes yeah when you go
inside and you finger somebody
you kind of got to go up into this i was
like yeah oh my god nobody
david's studying at night he's like [ __ ]
okay so but i kid you not a lot of the
stuff that i
learned from her is the majority of the
stuff that i do now because she was so
vocal with it i will tell you this
though when i had a huge dry spell where
i wasn't hooking up with anybody i
forgot all that [ __ ] oh really yeah they
lost it and that's kind of like
you said that was your second girl that
was third oh see that was my second
that was my second girlfriend she was uh
she was
way more experienced in that field that
kind of like
but she basically like taught me
everything that i do right so it's
almost basically the same exact story
there was like
she knew what she wanted she would tell
me how she wanted [ __ ] and that type of
stuff
and it was like that was like i got
introduced to like
toys right and [ __ ] like that not for
like me but like you know to put around
like your
dick when you're [ __ ] and [ __ ] like
that right so i never liked
toys i i wasn't a big fan i was not a
big fan too much
talking about the cockering is that yeah
yeah but one of them had like a little
vibrator on top of it
i wasn't a big fan of it but i mean she
did like she
basically what you just said like taught
almost everything that i kind of use
to this day because you know i'll be
[ __ ]
i'm here for you i'm here for you just
joking if you hit me up on my like no
singles though
yeah i mean that's dope like that like a
girl like that that really shows you
what's up i mean once you kind of get
the
like the the plate it's like there's
little variations here and there but
like
yeah the up thing
i feel like it takes time for me because
when i was when i first started like
when
i had a girl too that liked it as well
and she was like say something to me say
something and it was like
like i was like 19 20 and i was like i
literally said i don't know what to say
i was [ __ ] like i don't know what to
say like i'm not angry like your father
left you for a reason
yeah just hurt her soul [ __ ] do your
case yeah
but i've never had a girl that's told me
that they want
that either like they want me to dirty
taco i feel like it happens here and
there but it's not like somewhere
they're like oh that
if it happens genuinely like just let it
you gotta that's one of those things you
just have to feel you know
like if you're thinking like in the
morning like when i [ __ ] becca today i'm
going to think
you dirty [ __ ] and then when you say
it's going to come out like you dirty
slot if it's a weird
like i did on that netflix show last
night daddy daddy you know what
that bank account looking deep now
i didn't like it the way she liked it
though she was kind of
too aggressive yeah do you know what i
mean she would like she would want me to
like
like choke her choker two hands like
choke her the [ __ ] out
i'm like i'm murdering this woman she's
like turning red or
guys are getting all blood shots two
hands is the next level yeah like
and like the way she would like to be
spanked too was so
odd like i it was like you could see
like a welt on like my hand on her
some girls are crazy bro so that's what
i'm saying whatever sex that she had
with her
previous boyfriend was [ __ ] i had a
friend that told me
he was he was with this one girl and
while they were doing it
she said hit my ribs
and he was telling us the story and he
looked at my mole because it was
literally the next day
and he was just like bro that was
because we knew i knew this girl she was
kind of like friends with our group and
they like
started hooking up but he was just so
like kind of taken back so like we saw
him the next day he's like
yeah we were doing it she's like hit my
ribs and he's like i was doing it and i
didn't say anything because i thought
she was just talking
and she said it again hit my ribs and he
was like
what do you mean she's like punch me in
my ribs
so he said that he was doing it and he
he's like
he's like i hit her a little bit and he
was like she was like
no hit me punch me in my ribs he's like
so i literally like
punched her in her side and she
genuinely liked it he's like
i don't know if i'm gonna hook up with
her again it's weird
a little bit you never know if they're
that crazy like yeah you don't know what
they're gonna
do like they could just be like that
dude rape me and he punched me in the
[ __ ] you know what i mean like i don't
punch me in the ring if it's a new girl
you don't take anything you [ __ ] like a
gentleman
proper no choking no nothing no evidence
besides penis
very gentle no bruises patrick patrick
mickey mouse i know he [ __ ] the girl
looks like what's with these cute this
is not a cry
yeah but it's funny because i had a
friend of mine her name is frieza and
she came on and she started telling her
weird hookup stories right
on the podcast she told this funny ass
story about
one of her hookups about this dude that
would [ __ ] her
but he would always have to rub his
nipples
like what as she so when she was giving
her he would rub his own nipple
rub his own [ __ ] like she didn't want
him like no exaggeration he didn't want
her to rub his nipples
he was doing it i feel like i would want
her so they were like kind of they were
kind of smashed and they hooked up at
night and she was like
thinking in her head just [ __ ]
rub his nipples last night
you know yeah she was like kind of
giving it a pass like nah i was smashed
i don't know what's going on
so in the morning they woke up and they
were hooking up again and so
you know he was hitting it from the back
on her right and then she was kind of
like thinking as she's getting [ __ ]
like
is this is he rubbing his nipples right
now and she said as she's getting hit
from the back she turns around
he's like the russian gangs or like
circular
circular rubbing is [ __ ] nipples
right like
his nipples like
what was it the new york gangs
alex
and i think for her she's like listen if
we're if i'm wifey
we do whatever yeah i mean but it's the
first time we hooked up no you don't
tell me you freaked me the [ __ ] out yeah
yeah you can't do the weird [ __ ] i just
did you have to evolve into the weird
[ __ ]
the one i guess weird thing that i don't
like doing the mind choking and [ __ ] but
for me when i'm doing it and like we're
in the mood
like my teeth get really sensitive so
like i like to like
bite on something so like i like grind
my i like
grind my teeth or some [ __ ] like that
that's for what i think it's because
let me finish it let me finish it i
think it's because one of my girls she
used to like me like
get like biting on her neck a little bit
and [ __ ] like that and i think i got so
used to that like biting on her shoulder
or something like that
so like when i'm doing it like i feel
like i'm like oh i need a bite
so when you get horny your teeth start
to tingle and [ __ ] bro yeah like i like
grinding my teeth
oh my god so we're in a room here i know
we're like alex be horn [ __ ] somebody
dude everybody watch out no no no no
that's like the only really thing but
yeah like you like to bite then you're a
biter
yeah a little bit if but obviously i'm
not like trying to eat [ __ ] up
and [ __ ] but
no i think the weirdest story that i've
heard like from someone i knew was the
punching
the [ __ ] punching is that that was
the really that was really weird
especially
because garcia because i knew that we
knew the girl right
like i knew the girl so it was a little
like when he told us we're like damn
she's like into that [ __ ]
yeah well it was weird but yeah he hit
her with that rhyme
i've had girls tell me to slap him and
choke him and stuff like that no i never
like slapped because i was like this
kind of like
i it's just not in like it wouldn't be
wait face slap or booty slowly space
sliding
that's like kind of standard process and
you ever slap a titty though
no no no not in like a in a funny way i
have
like yeah shits and what is that thing
called when you run with somebody and do
that i don't know but
yeah you do that to a fat person yeah
they just happened happen to me too all
the time
but no yeah no that was true that was
the funniest thing dude remember because
uh honestly okay most of the girls i've
hooked up with have liked getting choked
like that's been a common thing i feel
like i feel like the majority
and then i remember i hooked up with a
girl and it was the same thing where i
was like okay it seems like girls just
like this
you know like it seems like they're into
this and i like went i was like okay
well i want to please this girl that i'm
having sex with she's like so i went i
reached and i was like gonna choke and
her eyes like got why and she's like
what are you
doing and i was like uh what and she was
like yeah what what the [ __ ] are you
doing like don't choke me and i was like
oh i'm sorry and i didn't i
wanted to say other girls like this but
that would have killed the moment
with a girlfriend i'm sorry i didn't
know she was like yeah yeah just don't
do that and then i was like okay
but it like popped me in my rib and then
she does
kick me in the [ __ ] chest dog
yeah don't choke
actually just give me a [ __ ] elbow
right to my nose real quick people's
elbow to the
puss she's like put me in a full nelson
real quick
yeah so you got to be careful you just
gotta you know just communicate a little
bit
it's all communication remember the last
time i did a choke is
now that like but you did a choke that
actually got [ __ ] right now uh
it was funny because like it was it was
with the previous girl that i had been
with like years
before but it was now like when i was
deep in powerlifting and [ __ ] like that
right
like the way
and she was like uh she asked me to
choke her so i start doing it
and literally like literally two seconds
and i was like oh she's like remember
you're really strong
now oh i was like oh [ __ ] my bad
powerlifter murdered her
murderer she says [ __ ] four dents
from your hand fingers on her neck
like yo what the [ __ ] happened vertebrae
out of place
yeah [ __ ] sex preferences are always
like the weirdest thing i always
i found out early on whatever you had
working with that other girl before it's
going to change for the next girl after
you just got to be able to like adjust
right and that's your heart
yeah i'm telling y'all slap a titty man
[ __ ] though
do you slap one and so that it hits the
other one yeah or do you
go across and slap you start in the
middle or one two
does one transfer the momentum
you know what it was that turned me on
about the tattoo slide was just the
titty jiggle it wasn't the actual slap
yeah i just like the way that titty used
to jiggle that's what i like about ass
yeah i think that's like doggy style
that's why doggy style is like so
preferred i feel like yeah ass and
gravity like the
effects that gravity like produces nice
that should be that ripple effect
the little the little rock like that
mandalay baby
yeah i mean i don't know i don't i don't
know i'm not prefer small titties yeah
but i don't mind it as much
my favorite that's your favorite so what
if it was a big titty big booty
i wouldn't mind being like [ __ ] no what
the [ __ ] yuck
get out of here with those big ass
titties no i mean obviously i would like
it but
like for some reason girls like that
have you have you seen the list of the
women he thinks is attractive
yeah they're the buffest dudes i've ever
seen
[Laughter]
yo this dude in our threads would be
like ay she fine as [ __ ]
right and i'm like where's the she at
yeah yeah like
nah there's no dis on them but they tend
to have a lot of masculine features
and they look like they could protect me
for the rest of my life i really do
yeah yeah they're strong but they're
sorry i'm not gonna say their names but
there's something that is that are bad
who so that ryan garcia body shot all
right
amanda amanda rebus oh amanda rebus is
bad
holmes is his holly holm is fine to me
she's fine bro
she uh she has a cute personality and i
think
i like her she's a brazilian girl that
just uh she just fought a little while
kenzie yeah mackenzie
you know who beat up uh mackenzie dern
who amanda rebus
oh man they should run it back though
they should but i think amanda reba
still wins amanda rebus is real good bro
honestly i don't remember what amanda
rebus looks like right now
he's bad i'll show you guys show me pull
her up my phone
mackenzie dern though mackenzie turner
is but kenzie dern is really attractive
uh rachel ostovich
yes
but she's bomb but kevin you don't just
got that speech impediment that
developed out of nowhere
uh yeah because she has the accent now
right she's she's brazilian yeah but
well she's
grew up in arizona her whole life and
then she moved to port like portugal or
whatever brazil for a little bit
she came back and now she can't speak in
english she's like hi guys
how old was she when she moved she was
must have been like 20 something
what yeah [ __ ] out of here bro wait wait
what are you talking about
she's like born and raised went to high
school there's videos of her speaking
normal like just normal because she was
in arizona like
her class is cute i like him you have to
watch the video
of wait there's a video compilation of
her english being perfect valley girl
going all the way to broken english bro
no
wait what okay so she moved when she was
20 to brazil
just recently not that long ago yeah she
went there for a little bit and then she
even came back she wasn't even out there
for that long wait
and now she can't speak english she she
can but
she has a big accent very strong
brazilian because
i saw her interview in the last fight
she was only speaking portuguese so
because i thought she was going to speak
english because i was like oh she looks
like she's white
uh american girl started speaking
portuguese yeah i started speaking
portuguese i was like oh [ __ ] and then
it showed the brazilian flag i was like
oh [ __ ] my bad i thought i thought she
was
she is she's like from arizona yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
so she's crazy
yeah she's crazy like her thing yeah her
father is like a big you know jiu jitsu
guy they're from brazil
and all that type of stuff but that was
that's always been the story about her
is
how her accent has changed over the
years dude arrow helwani is a savage too
because he's interviewing her right
he goes so what's with the accent yeah
i love that yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah i don't
know
because we understand like sometimes
when you move to another place like
especially
if you're at a young age you could lose
your accident at a young age but she's
only been there for a little bit and she
comes back and then
the weird thing is like [ __ ] weird i
understand if you pick up slang or maybe
a little bit of your [ __ ] gets twisted a
bit
but she would just like forget english
words you know
like i it's like yeah she wanted me to
translate her off yeah
like when i when i practice my jujitsu i
have to sit down
in chair like sit down in chair
why what what what's with the
grammatical structure like
it doesn't make any sense that's weird
yeah that's crazy i think she explained
it one time saying that
it was her or maybe someone else or
someone that said that maybe they think
maybe that's happening because when
she's in brazil she's literally
only speaking uh portuguese but that's
like me and my household i only speak
korean to my parents growing up
but i didn't i didn't come out here with
the body it's a mere damage
yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah i never in
mexico for long periods of time and now
come back like hey
me i need to work it yeah you know i
wasn't like i can speak english
yeah right no yeah i don't know it's
it's pretty weird though because you can
find videos of her
just speaking like clean normal english
valley girl eating yeah that's so weird
and then that's weird that's [ __ ]
weird
really weird yeah you're definitely
having like this weird identity coaching
yes
[ __ ] going on yeah but she could choke
me out any day and she's bomb yeah
she is her jiu-jitsu was [ __ ] nuts or
mma
her last oh not her last match but the
one before that dude oh yeah
doctor bar against random marcos oh that
[ __ ] was nuts dude i didn't see it
dude is a beast she is good the moment
grabs you you're [ __ ]
like because the what what she can do on
the ground is so beyond just typical mma
jiu jitsu oh yeah you know
it's like the way she sets things up i i
can't because i don't know just do
enough right but
enough in mma where i can see what's
happening when she does her [ __ ] i don't
know what she's doing
it's like it's it's the feeling like
when when jack ray would get someone
down
when everybody's like oh you're before
that knock the [ __ ] out
yeah i know oh my god or it's the
feeling like when
damian maya would get somebody down it's
the same thing with mackenzie during if
she gets you down you're like oh it's
over and you're
[ __ ] because yeah you know or oliver
against ferguson
oh yeah oliveira bro weird fight dude
fergus is done
oliver looked [ __ ] fantastic yeah
dude
out of him dude drastically yeah
domination we had talked about this on
the
show we recorded it was my thing is i
think tony ferguson needs a team
oh yeah he doesn't take any coaching he
doesn't pay anybody and it was so weird
on the embedded they were like
they were like uh oh you're so we told
your coach that's not my coach
that's not my coach he's my training
partner ask me who my coach is and she's
like
she's your coach me it's like okay
cool that's [ __ ] weird yeah but but
then you can see it's not really
working out for him anymore just
engaging now he also can't take the same
damage that he used to because it's not
like in any of his previous fights he
wasn't he's
he's never not gotten [ __ ] up on the
feet he's just
nuts yeah right very weird very awkward
the gay she only took a lot like that's
like
dos santos uh uh vasquez level of like
damage where that changes your [ __ ]
career
like that's a career-changing level of
the point where you feel bad for the
fighter yeah that was
i was like [ __ ] like it could have been
stopped around or too early
it almost looked like he could have died
yes my thing is
his awkwardness and just like kind of
freestyle fighting
was working right but at some point it's
going to stop working
yeah and it looks like it stopped
working but also oliveira
like not to take anything away from like
that [ __ ] looks sharp yeah yeah
he looked
also like i think you're right but also
oliveira look like on point to like
where that dude needs to fight for a
title of course that dude looked [ __ ]
and he looked big
i remember like watching them like when
they were walking and they were by each
other i'm like damn this guy is actually
he looks big dude my favorite tony
ferguson interview was him
was him and for fabricio verdum i know
huh and then
we're doing just calling him the whole
thing
and ferguson's like look at he goes get
the [ __ ] out of your ankle pick you
that's his response and you just hear
[ __ ] verdoom calling your modicone
throughout the whole thing
and he had to do a whole statement about
how he doesn't hate gay people
but like wow would literally like that's
another guy if he gets you down
yeah it's over we're doing would
obviously smash the [ __ ] out of tony
ferguson
in my personal opinion of course like
he's just [ __ ]
huge bro of course he's better than you
at jiu jitsu and he's
100 yeah look what happens more than
[ __ ] gusts in dude
once he grabbed him it was done over the
one way gusting could lose
is by if rear [ __ ] boom took him down
and
then submitted him and that's literally
what happened what a sad comeback for
[ __ ] gusting i know i hope he comes
back though because that's like the
i feel like verdum can be the one of the
heart i think verdum and francis and
ganu
are probably like the hardest fights in
the heavyweight division
in the sense of if you get taken down by
verdum you have a
very low chance of surviving it yeah and
if you're
striking with francis and ganu you have
a
very low chance no actually verdum left
though he left ufc yeah
yeah so he did he beat uh gus and then
he left and now he's he's part of pfl
pfl be paying that's why yeah pf and he
he might just
he might win that he's also like 45 so
it's like might as well just go for the
paycheck
out yeah i hope gus comes back and even
if it's a heavyweight because
i think he could still be champ even
when jon jones going there what do you
think about jones
how do you think jones is going to do i
think jones is going to do good i just
here's my thing it's like i know i'm not
i'm smart you know i've been into mma
for a long time and it's like
but still when you see and you know you
can't just go oh well that guy is a
knockout artist so he'll beat anybody
you can't always think about that but
no no just in general but like when you
see francis and ganu like oh yeah it's
just scary bro
it's like it's hard to not think that
because that's the hardest matchup i
think even over steep it i think stephen
jones is a really good matchup
but i like jones uh against ngandu i'm
like dude i don't think he's gonna miss
these i think ghana beats him
on anybody bro it's over it's it's it's
a wrap it's a wrap and it's
he probably doesn't even need his
hardest punch on you and i keep saying
this too like everybody needs to go back
and watch the highlights of ngaru
and watching ganu before he contacts
somebody he gets hit in the face three
times and he doesn't do anything
yeah it's like biggie boy you see that
he hit him lip crack
slip crack nothing yeah
looks like it's like a lion yeah it
really does it looks so wide
the nicest guy on earth too yeah so nice
and so i'm just like
yeah i just when i think about the stipe
rematch i'm kind of just like
just retire yeah even over him you know
over him when he got uppercutted to like
another universe
you hit him with the overhand first yeah
he connected it's clean
he just didn't do anything yeah yeah
nothing and stipe their first fight
stipe hit him with
bombs bombs and stipe knocks people out
yeah he hits hit him with bombs and
francis and ghana just stood there dead
[ __ ] tired like
i cannot breathe you're just like oh my
god he loves beat his ass
yeah that's why i'm like i love steeping
i've been a big stipe fan but i'm
i really wish i was hoping he was gonna
retire before this fight
i i was hoping that he beat dc and
retired
because he has who's he fighting next is
he fighting jones if he beats
if he beats ingano a second yeah he's
the best heavyweight of all time
100 percent yeah i honestly don't think
he's the in the ufc at least he's the
best heavyweight
obviously because he's beat he beat a
lot of people he beats
twice he beat this yeah twice he beat
the one guy that everybody was terrified
to fight
he beat him and he did it like kane is
the only one
where he like the running velocis
said that he was healthy when he fought
in ganu he was not his knee gave out so
fast
but i honestly i still think that it was
the punch that made his knee
cave in because when you watch it like
and if you when you watch it close
he gets hit and then his knee goes and
you just know
he got rocked yeah knowing how hard and
gano hits i'm like that makes
sense like well well kate velasquez and
the whole like
jds [ __ ] yeah yeah that was so nuts
just watching them go back and forth it
was just
that's when jds was like jda like he
wasn't he was no slouch you know what i
mean jds changed after those
beatings that he took oh for sure you
can't get hit like that and expect to be
the same person
yeah he also just never evolved his game
he still throws that stupid uppercut
against the cage and he keeps getting
cracked
yeah like and curtis blade's like watch
this
what was that dude he just fought the
french dude the french don
that dude was pretty pretty pretty he's
a really clean like dutch kickboxing
yeah yeah he's clean he's super
bouncy jds isn't who he was but i feel
bad for that one because it
like it's a lot of controversy he
definitely hit the back of that yeah it
was back of the head and i feel bad for
jds because he was already on i think a
three fight losing streak yeah
and they were all knockouts or tkos but
like another one like you know the
and the ufc dana white came out saying
that they were gonna cut a bunch of
fighters so
i feel bad because that was kind of i
mean it was behind the head
if he meant to do it or not i actually
just rewatched the fight
and re-watching it and low-key it kind
of
not saying that he did it purposely but
right before he throws the elbow it
looks like he like pushes jds
more this way so like it exposed way
more of the back of the head before he
threw the elbow
yeah i mean he was so bad he was
definitely getting his ass beaten yeah
either way
but it that was definitely behind the
head that was straight up behind the
dome
shot yeah so they should be able to run
it back yeah i think
they should i think like jds should just
call it though yeah it's over bro
like no more why why why he's one where
i'm just like yeah i think
you were the champ already hey man you
know savant like savannah is the best
too he goes
because there's a specific fighter that
we know
he still isn't retired right so switched
into a different fighting style instead
of mma now
but the guy has crazy cte like the worst
cte ever
so i remember i asked savannah hey so
how did he do when you were training him
he was like
you know all i can say is this like some
fighters this is all that they know
they don't know anything else but you
try to take that away from them what do
they got
yeah right i'm not here to tell somebody
when they should retire if this is the
thing that keeps them going i'm just
going to do my job and help them train
for the fight other than that
it's done this guy's like cte is bad
damn and he loves doing podcasts
oh really the worst oh my god
i'll show you a video later you know
exactly what i'm talking about but it's
it's terrible because i love this guy
like i used to look up this dude as a
kid
but then you know he's asking me advice
about how to do podcasts and [ __ ] and i
see him doing like podcasts
and it's obviously it's getting no views
because nobody understands what the [ __ ]
you saying
right hey we're gonna talk about is
going around standing here
man i'm like what did you just say
all right yeah but it's because it's not
he's not like mentally
challenged it's his brain damage from
all the fights that he's had
and i saw his boxing match that he had
not too long ago
and now i understand why this fool just
gets hit in the head all the [ __ ]
time
and now his pro boxing record is
terrible dude
and he's not he's not even losing by
tko's he's he's losing by a decision
getting he doesn't get knocked out yeah
but
the the aftermath of that is him talking
like the way he does now
trying to do podcasts yeah i just i came
across a video of mike tyson with
muhammad ali
and like and he's like look watch the
feet have you seen that one he's like
watching he does the shuffle
and then you just look at muhammad ali
you're like damn that [ __ ] it's crazy
like what
he's got uh crazy yeah it's just crazy
to see
how how bad it got him yeah
it's [ __ ] insane because he was like
so loud and talkative right and [ __ ]
like that and like he couldn't even like
talk
like the worst of it he was hanging
there late man yeah
as [ __ ] yeah it was it was pretty crazy
i'm just
thinking ali is fine or no i don't
remember what she looks like but i
remember i seen the i'm
remembering on the clip where she
knocked a girl out and in that clip
she looked pretty fine hey i don't know
no but all i know is have you guys ever
seen 60 days in
no the tv show so there's one there's a
season on netflix which is
[ __ ] it's so [ __ ] dope like that was
one of the shows where i watched the
first episode and i
literally uh it was during the covet
scare so i got to watch the whole thing
because i didn't go to work or anything
so i literally watched the whole season
just [ __ ] straight
uh but so i started re-watching the the
new
the other seasons so on hulu they have
the other seasons
and the first one the first season
there's this like there's like a heavier
set
uh black woman on there she's and she's
talking and [ __ ]
and me and my mom are watching like well
she looks like
familiar kind of and [ __ ] like that and
she's talking and she's like my name i
forget her first name something ali
and she goes yes i'm muhammad ali's
daughter
i'm like damn okay right when she said
that you're like she looks
exactly she looks like muhammad she
looks like she has like muhammad ali
she's pretty fine though yeah yeah i'm
like oh because i was looking up a video
because who's that uh olympic boxer
that's getting into mma she's talking a
lot of [ __ ] oh uh yeah uh
clarissa shields clarissa shields right
she's dope yeah she is
dope film female boxer right dope hands
i don't know mma you know she's talking
a lot of [ __ ]
saw her kicks about other [ __ ] i mean
she just started yeah that's the only
thing that
supposedly that video is old okay so am
i okay so but like
release a new one to kind of like like
watch us know
let us know laila ali and clarissa
shields had a little beef
oh yeah because you know she's retired
they're not even the same weight class
but then layla was like she was i guess
clarissa shields you know she talks a
big game three-time olympic boxer blah
blah blah champion whatever
and she said she could beat layla ali's
ass and laila ali is like
i'll come out of retirement i'll [ __ ]
you up then make make the money right
i'll go i'll come out of retirement
right now and i'll put it on you i'm
like
damn that will be fun my teeth about to
grind real soon
right now no i you know honestly
i think that she could i think that she
could do good she's with a good team
but she chose jackson wink which is a
good spending with john jones
training with jon jones holly holm my
little baddie holly holm you know
but i don't know i it's just we all know
that mma is like is it different it's a
different game bro
100 so take down defense needs to be on
point also your boxing skills don't
transfer
over completely because you're worried
about [ __ ] taking you down
there's not that many izzy's
izzy's one of the ones that has yeah no
wrestling but he
i love him he's so good he's his
wrestling takedown
and just the way he he handled his like
so remember when jon jones first came
out he was trying to be like this like
son of god like preacher like the face
[ __ ]
is he just embrace the yeah i'm kind of
like i'm braggadocious i i handle my
[ __ ] but this is me
like yeah like lamborghini like he just
embraced it he's the embodiment of
this is me i can be a dick sometimes but
i'm also cool [ __ ] it
and it's like yeah this guy's dope at
least he's being real and he handles his
[ __ ] like if jon jones would have gone
that route he would have been dope as
[ __ ] no one would have hated him
yeah jon jones saddest thing is that he
is the biggest reason why
nobody likes him yeah yeah he's just 100
it's just like
he's i think he's like bipolar because
he doesn't
at first i was thinking like oh it could
be a marketing ploy thing i'm like nah
but it doesn't come off as a marketing
ploy it's not like you know jake paul
when he's talking his [ __ ] it's just a
corny dude just trying to get sales
right
but for him it's like oh yeah that's
just you like you have a weird god
complex
yeah like you you could just go ahead
and shift your ideals constantly and you
think that it's completely fine
i want to thank god for all this other
[ __ ] but at the same time you're on
twitter talking this [ __ ] it's like
that's the most ungodly
yeah the deleted tweets all that [ __ ]
bro it's just so fancy
that sucks too because i'm like a huge
jon jones fan
so are you really yeah that's like from
beginnings it was like
you know chuck liddell vanderlei silva
and like jon jones were like my favorite
fighter so i've been a
jon jones fan for a very long time but
it's like also it's like
i can see why people don't like it
fighting-wise he's undeniable
fighting-wise he's he's he's a beast
animal i mean i don't
he's tall and stuff he has like natural
gifts but
iq toughness like he's got it all uh
it's just the way what the rashad evans
fight is when i started to
because i was always kind of unsure
about him but then when he fought rashad
and rashad was like you're fake bro like
you're fake like and he knew him like
rashad knew him knew him and then you
would see like the deleted tweets all
that [ __ ] and i was like oh rashad was
right you know
what yeah that's the thing about him too
it's like i will say this though i did
agree with one of his tweets he goes
i left the division because i wasn't
challenged enough and i could see this
fight oh yeah
when he fought anthony smith and he was
just letting him coast when he could
have
clearly knocked him out early on because
he was already f he already [ __ ]
anthony smith in his head
you know yeah he just kind of was
playing with him yeah you know and even
when he was fighting uh what's his face
um
dominic dominic i'm like he didn't look
like he was all there it
doesn't look like he's taking anybody
seriously yeah division so it's like you
know what it is time for you to leave
heavyweight you need to be scared now
sure because the way he's fighting he's
fighting them like i could beat you any
[ __ ] day and i can knock you out
whenever so i'm just going to coast like
why
don't you try yeah right you know yeah i
mean i'm interested to see this i just
was listening to something today and
dana white was doing an interview
saying that they're not giving him the
title shot right away so they're going
to give him a heavyweight fight
i think they should give him aleister
over him because like that's a fight
that's big
because they're both big names you know
uh alistair
won i think his last three yeah he's
been on a winning streak dude yeah
he's so crazy bro yeah he's been
fighting forever gotten knocked out a
hundred times bro
goes on losing streaks goes on these fat
winning streaks get to the title losing
streaks winning streaks like
that's like bro andre was just like on a
five-fight
winning streak yeah is he still in the
ufc yeah yeah he lost his last he lost
his last one but it was like a
it was a kind of a boring fight it was a
really boring yeah i remember him
fighting tim
sylvia yeah me too and knocking
back in the day made me want it like
when i was like man i want to grow up
i want to have a hairy ass chest bro
cause this guy looks like a [ __ ]
beast
yeah because he was all hairy as [ __ ]
wolverine
yeah he looks like he never has
consensual sex
[Laughter]
the choking and slapping happens no
matter what you're doing what do you
mean that's how you have sex
you ask yes and they say no then you do
it anyway
you know yeah i i used to like him a lot
but that's what the days when i was
first watching ufc was like
him and the tim sylvia i think they did
a trilogy right i think they did three
three two
i think one two out of three yeah and
then like uh okay i just remember two of
them i don't know if those
tim sylvia got his arm broken by what's
it frank mirror i remember watching that
yeah
he still hasn't healed from that [ __ ]
that's just [ __ ] up yeah i remember
watching that you know tim sylvia is
like
big now right like fat fat yeah they did
they had on
fight pass they had like the where they
are now
and like he's like uh he has a big
hunting show
like on youtube and [ __ ] like that like
he's making a lot of money
like a lot of money and [ __ ] but he's
big you know who was a beast with shane
carwin
shane carmen he kind of he like [ __ ]
up against brock lesnar he blew his wad
hard because he had lesnar he just
talked about this he just blew his watch
yeah i was just
but he was the last animal brock lesnar
was so i forget who the ref was in that
fight
but he was so lucky it was that rough
because
we've seen fights get stopped so much
faster
for so much less damage shane carbon at
one point was literally just like
talking in the face yeah okay like what
else do you need me to [ __ ] do
brock lesnar's literally just like this
and the ref just let it go
forever because they're trying to curate
brock lesnar yeah and let him survive as
much as possible but i mean but
he did end up winning he did yeah but he
survived but i'm like i'm saying
perfect ref for that night because that
was kind of early when he got hurt
and shane carl was sitting there just
punching him punching himself
out yeah he blew for like a minute and a
half bro when the fight could have
easily been stopped
and then yeah he was [ __ ] gas he
looked like me doing one round of admits
probably
done hey this 2021 is your year though
right i know we're about to get mad
that's what one of my resolutions i was
talking was starting to lose weight
but also i want to start looking into
like uh refereeing
hey let's do one thing at a time man and
then also
also i want to let's let's drop that
weight first then we're going to referee
next
all right let's not jump these hoops
real quick huh no but i was talking to
nick nick
nick was like oh you should really do it
actually i really think that nick
he's just positive as [ __ ] i'm telling
you no he's not bro i tell nick one time
on my a nick
i think i'm gonna buy a bike to buy car
do cardio no i don't buy that
i'm like why no don't buy a bike that's
because
you don't even walk i was like baby
steps yeah cause walking's
boring bro if it's a bike it's a bike
yeah why don't you do you should do it
by spiking it behind my man
but also also you should start
meditating dude for the anxiety
100 breathing hey you can't
underestimate a breath i know you can't
understand you know what that breath
feel like that right
yeah yeah i underestimate the breath
though yeah that breath do be hitting
sometimes you know hit that breath
dude get that breath take that breath
and you just yeah biking's i mean i got
a bike with a little
electric little juice in it yeah i mean
help me out a little bit david's like
this
and then everybody's away he's like oh
[ __ ] they're watching
you have to pedal on this you can't not
pedal and have it go but it's for like
uh it's it's for long distances i mean
people
they bike 100 miles i can't do that
right because my thing is just for
it's for like fun and it's also for
exercise
so the days i want to exercise no
electricity which is hard because the
bike's like 30 pounds
but it looks like a regular bike yeah
okay but that's
that's the difficult part like just
don't use like it's 30 [ __ ] pounds
it's a heavy [ __ ] bike
but then if i put it on like pedal
assist one then it kind of helps cruise
it a little bit not much just because
i'm also a big boy
but it's fun though man i think i'm more
interested in like uh mountain biking
damn i'm scared that's just like well
like even like remember what joe was
doing for a little bit he was going to
like that park
that's an arrowhead so yeah hour away
yeah that see actually looks [ __ ] fun
to me like that's what i want my dad's a
big biker
hey you got to do things that you're
going to do consistently you ain't going
to be going to arrowhead every day
hey you say that bro when i was fishing
fishing like when i was fishing fishing
every weekend i was driving up to big
bear i was driving to these lakes
they're like an hour and a half away
biking one weekend out of the week and
gonna do shifting i would bike
throughout the week though
no because i know trails like where i
used to walk dogs and like i would see
people riding their bikes there all the
time yeah like
i know so i'm gonna give you a month to
buy a bike i better see you cruising
with them little doily little things on
the side
are you sure you've ridden a bike before
yes i have it's just the other one had
those those
those wheels on the back
that's just funny well you should get a
bike get a bike [ __ ] i should yay
hey this month you better get a bike and
you can ride with me i do easy like
15 miles
50 miles yeah man 50 miles we just put
the boombox on we listened to music it
was right
that's dope boombox too [ __ ] feel good
i did 30 miles last week your boy almost
died
like we went so far out towards the
beach because we went we started i think
i saw your post
marina del rey all the way to torrance
damn so that was like 15 16 and 15 16
back [ __ ] me
and then we didn't time it really well
so on the way back it got super dark and
then my battery went on my lights so i
was riding in the dark
hella scary oh my god yes yeah i like i
like biking and i know i will because we
like as kids that was something that me
and my brothers
like at one point we're doing a lot was
riding our bikes like we had
i i had a like a free agent and my
brother had
i don't know what other style but like i
remember we my dad helped us we sand it
down and we painted it like these cool
colors but
we were like doing the bunny hops and
tricks and [ __ ] we would just ride our
bikes
every single day like it was fun to us
so i know riding bikes would be fun
that's what i've always done the only
thing is they are kind of expensive
all right you can get a used bike 300
all right damn i'm gonna i'm gonna set
you up hey hey shout out to stimulus
even though it hasn't hit the count yet
i know [ __ ] mine has
a waiting for that i didn't get my
stimuli either dude i know give me life
yeah
but [ __ ] i might i'm gonna get some
glasses for sure because i need glasses
just a pair of glasses and then the blue
ones are for the tv or
the real no no just like actual glasses
okay okay
um and then uh yeah i'll probably buy a
bike i really want to
that's something i really want to if it
doesn't happen this month i've given up
on you man
well everybody you can find uh alex at
lyft god
on all of this stuff you can see him on
twitch gaming and [ __ ] because he's not
gonna be riding his bike he's gonna be
gaming
no i'll ride the bike and then i'll ride
the bike and then
and then the game hell yeah yeah you
ain't going wrong
yeah you can find patrick at patrick.t
dot riley
at instagram and genius brains every
thursday and sundays and we'll see you
all next time
peace